joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line it's last week uh or two
weeks ago we had nolan ryan on the
program that he's number one all time on
the all-time strikeouts list now we've
got number two on that list and he is a
baseball hall of famer who is a 10-time
all-star four-time saw young award
winner and he's one of the legends that
fans will have a chance to play with in
mlb the show 22.
randy johnson you're you're sliding me a
cy young i have i'm five times so young
but that's okay oh my gosh well listen
uh i can only you know go with what the
folks put in front of me here because i
i forgot how many cy youngs you had five
times i got one i got one at last i
counted i got one in seattle and four in
arizona so that would be five but maybe
they were just uh saying the four that i
had in arizona i'm not sure no let me uh
let me check on this no i it's i'm i'm
somebody's about to be fired randy so
uh the heads are gonna roll that's the
way i roll that's the way i operate yeah
nobody crosses me like that anyways how
are you randy
i'm doing great i'm doing wonderful yeah
uh fantastic so uh let me just jump into
what the here and now is the number of
times i keep hearing about you know
randy johnson was there taking
photographs of something i i've lost
track so what are you up to and how
often are you out um you know with your
camera doing your doing your thing randy
well before uh
baseball uh became a real thing in my
life i uh
was going to usc and i studied
photojournalism and so that's where
my photography kind of uh began
and then uh obviously four years in the
minor leagues in 22 years at the major
league level there wasn't a lot of time
for photography and so when i retired in
2009 i started to uh
you know dust off the camera equipment
learn how to
to use a camera again and then since
then i've gone on numerous uso tours uh
to support our men and women that are uh
around the world and then just on a lot
of trips in general and uh you know
concerts uh africa various things like
that so uh
nothing is uh a set schedule for me but
uh in the last couple years there really
hasn't been a lot going on just because
the code right
so
what do you want to take pictures of or
or document that you have not had an
opportunity to do yet and you're like
you know what i'd like to i'd like to to
be on the sideline or at a certain spot
you said concerts like what would you
prefer to what would you like to do well
i mean i i've been pretty fortunate that
i've been able to go to uh
you know i had some incredible access
for billy joel uh show up in seattle at
safeco field
the same concert here in arizona and had
all access elton john the same kind of
thing you know just kind of don't knock
anything over
uh step on any cords and disconnect the
power lines but yeah just uh have had
that ability to uh to take those kind of
pictures and then in exchange if they
need something from me
uh for social media or or something like
that a website uh then i'm more than
happy to uh to reciprocate after getting
the uh access that they've allowed me to
have uh
and then you know motorsports and and uh
in travel i think the greatest uh trips
i've gone on have probably been to
africa uh been to ethiopia i've trekked
through the mountains in rwanda to see
the silverback gorillas
and then and then naturally just uh bent
over to uh
uh the serengeti and the masamara to uh
to watch the great migration a few times
so uh
there's a lot of places in this world
that i like to go a lot of places that i
haven't been yet and uh
you know a lot of times i just find
interesting places by other
photographers and then start searching
it out
i love it randy johnson here on the rich
housing show how do you get access at
safegua who do you know you know
somebody there i don't understand how do
you get to i don't
come on
you don't just show up with sam randy
johnson no matter what's going on at
safeco you know
i i guess uh
you know if the kingdom would have been
there i probably would have had better
access but that that that's that's been
uh you know knocked down for for many
years now got it no i just uh i just
really enjoy
uh i think
i think the transition into retirement
now for quite a while now uh since 2009
has been made a little bit easier
uh simply because i have something that
i can um
you know enjoy that takes up some of my
time you know i also have a a place over
at the beach and uh you know it's not
out of the norm for me to have a camera
in my hand and and uh you know be taking
pictures of uh you know the guys surfing
there or over at the wedge uh when the
when the swells are pretty big so um
you know it's
really limitless you know with with
travel or going out in the ocean and
and uh seeing whales or you know things
like that that's kind of the stuff that
i i'm looking forward to doing uh this
summer it's randy johnson baseball hall
of famer here on the rich eisen show and
you mentioned how you know
um
you know
you were into photography for a long
time until baseball became a thing for
you
um so who how did baseball become a
thing for you i'd imagine that youth
uh managers or coaches and youth sports
kind of push you towards basketball did
that never was that
was that never
i did play i did play uh high school uh
basketball and baseball and uh it was
fun at the time for three out of the
four years uh and then when i got uh
got a scholarship to go to usc it was
theoretically
a half basketball half baseball
but
i essentially was just playing
uh the three years that i played there
at usc for rod dado it was all for
a baseball
and
i think uh you know i still hadn't come
into my own during college uh and then
four
and then i signed with the montreal
expos and then four years at the minor
league level you know still trying to
gain some control and consistency with
like mechanics and and then eventually
uh got called up in montreal and
during all this time you know there's
the biggest hindrance at that time but
uh also it was a double-edged sword the
biggest
attribute was my height and my leverage
and my ability to throw 95 to 100 it was
just a matter of becoming consistent and
not
um you know and trying to understand and
get it harnessed uh
that was probably the biggest uh
biggest challenge for me and it took it
took several years into the major
leagues and so you can imagine it was
always something that was
you know i was trying to
trying to keep under control so what
clicked what helped you click do you
remember i think you know there i mean
there was there was there was moments of
of real highlight games for me that was
in very encouraging and then you go back
out
and you know five days later as a
starting pitcher's schedule is and then
you don't have that same success and
then you start questioning your ability
and all that but i think eventually
inevitably uh in the kingdom my home for
ten years in seattle i had a nice
conversation with tom house and nolan
ryan
and uh and um
i i think it was probably
being in the american league west at the
time and and tom house being a former
usc trojan i think uh he took the time
to obviously see some mechanical flaws
that i still had
that that hadn't been corrected in high
school college four years in the minor
leagues or even the first couple years
in in in montreal or in seattle and it
was one small little thing
that uh they were going to show me when
nolan threw a bullpen session in the
kingdom and it was simply falling on the
ball of your foot
uh
your your landing leg and what i was
doing i was landing on the heel of my
foot
and that would
inevitably make my momentum
when i was
falling towards home plate or trying to
fall towards one plate my momentum would
be turning because my my
heel would be twisting and i would be
falling off towards the third base side
so inevitably they taught me and showed
me how to land on the ball of my foot
and then naturally my momentum went
towards home plate and i was able to
you know have everything follow and and
go towards home plate and i wasn't
losing my arm angle and my velocity was
staying the same and
it just became very impactful one small
little thing like that was really
what i was looking for
inevitably to remain consistent on those
games that occasionally i would have
those games became more consistent
and uh and i really actually started
having a lot of fun in the game when i
was able to see my ability and then i
just
tried to get more out of my ability
by
understanding the the the game itself
and how to pitch and so really i was
trying to find my mechanics and
and
you know the building blocks of being a
picture the you know most pitchers
already know about the mechanics and
aren't hindered by their
six foot ten frame that was that was the
downside but inevitably i was thankful
that i had a conversation with
uh house and and nolan and then from
that point on
i was playing catch-up if you will where
other pitchers were already ahead of me
because they already had their mechanics
i was
trying to catch up to them
in their ability to pitch and now i'm
learning how to pitch
with
with uh
the attributes that i have my fastball
and and my height and leverage and
and uh you know things started coming
into place and uh and it was a lot of
fun i i i it's such a strange question
to ask somebody who's number two on the
all-time list who just told a story
about the guy who's number one on the
all-time strikeouts list helping unlock
your potential in nolan ryan that's
incredible randy johnson but this is a
simple question if you are still
pitching today where everybody's
focusing on exit velocity and trying to
swing over a shift and and striking out
much of the time how many more
strikeouts do you think you could have
in today's game randy well i came close
to 400 one year in one season i came so
i i suspect that
uh if they were letting me go out and
pitch like i was
in the 90s and the 2000s
you know where i was allowed to throw
130 540 pitches in a game uh i would
probably uh i would probably you know
get to that get to that number uh but
unfortunately in today's game
um
no pitchers aren't allowed to go deep
into the games simply because they're
not allowed to throw that many pitches
in a game
so well and then there's but there's
also the analytics right third time
through the order i mean would a manager
ever be able to tell you you know
pinella i mean i don't think he'd be
that guy or it's such a different era
man i mean going up to you going up to
randy johnson saying need the ball randy
it's a third time through the order and
your numbers are such and such a thing i
mean i can't even imagine i can't well
and
analytics are important i'm not denying
that but i also don't want to deny the
ability that a player may have that he
never gets to
because he's never allowed to stay out
there and actually see what it's like to
get through a tough situation and extend
himself
um
and see what it's like to get out of uh
you know a situation that that pitchers
have been doing for
over a hundred years and i think when
you finally get in that position and you
see that you're
able to get through a situation like
that you get to the next level of
pitching and i think in today's game
there's not as many pitchers that are
allowed to do that as there was when i
was pitching and i'm thankful that i was
allowed to do that because then
it made me
grow as a pitcher i think it it allowed
me to see what it took you know this hey
this inning could take another 10
pitches and i'm gonna have to really
bear down and focus and i'm tired and
you know hitters are coming up and
you know
i just think you you gotta you gotta
really bear down and i and i think not
being put in that position
pitchers never know what it's going to
be like to get out of that position
because uh a pitcher's coming out of the
bullpen to relieve them and get out of
that situation so i think that's that's
the one thing i take from today's game
that i just wish that there was a little
bit more
of a leash
that was loosened for pitchers so they
could go out and pitch and really grow
as a pitcher
well i know and this is another odd
question ask somebody who's got damn
near 5 000 career strikeouts but it is
baseball
um
every pitcher always had some guy that
would wear him out was it who was that
guy that uh
there was uh it was a long list oh come
on seriously
as any pitcher would say
uh that's played 15 20 years over 20
years
you know not everybody was a strikeout
they gave up a lot of home runs and they
gave up a lot of hits and you know
there's a lot of people that have uh
that you know
if if i
met them i would probably owe them a
steak dinner just because they wore me
out uh you know mike piazza has good
numbers off me chipper jones has the
most home runs off me
um
and the the list is long and then you
know it just all depends on how many
at-bats are you talking like 10 at-bats
15 at-bats i mean we could go all the
way up to 20 at bats 30 at bats so then
i guess which one would it be where you
know you're going through your pitching
plan or whatever before your game and
you're like okay i know when this guy's
up it's going to be my
who who would be the guy that you were
just like
i can't think of any names right now but
like you know mike piazza or you said or
um chipper you know chipper jones
somewhere like that i i think you know
you handle
you you respect everybody that comes up
there and you also realize that you're
going to be doing damage control too
they may get their hit if they get their
hit if they get their home run off you
now you got to bear down and either
understand that
the person your nemesis is on deck and
so you need to get the person out
at the plate
so the person that comes up that your
nemesis isn't you know doing you know
you're trying to keep damage control in
play there i think uh but yeah i think
i'm sure you got
technicians there that
that could rattle off 10 people that
probably are batting over 500 off me
with more than 15 20 at bats and i think
that's a pretty good number of course it
is i mean did you ever did you ever face
griffey did that ever happen where he
moved on and you moved on and yeah well
i mean i played here in arizona and i
played with the yankees but more
importantly i i here with the the
diamondbacks uh
i was actually able to pitch a couple of
times up in safeco field uh when he was
still in seattle i think i think i faced
him like three times we actually talked
about that recently
uh faced him and edgar who i consider
one of the best hitters i've ever seen
no doubt um
i think uh i think i got junior out and
then i threw him a slider that backed up
a little bit he said he hit his elbow he
told the umpire so the umpire gave him
first base and i just looked at him
shook my head
like i like like come on man
stay in there let's head let's stay in
there i'll throw you my best step we'll
see what happens
i love it randy johnson here on the rich
eisen show okay so you are one of the
legends that fans can have a chance to
play with in mlb the show 22.
uh kurt gibson the 80 so the 84 kirk
gibson is going to be in the game 2000
carlos delgado who del got it a few
times uh dontrell willis from 2005 and
the version you're being uh you're in
this uh game with is the 95 version
you won your first psy
young award with the mariners is that
the the ver did you get a chance to
choose which version or you approved it
could you get to approve which version
i didn't get to pick which version i was
going to be but i did i did uh help
uh design what i was looking like i mean
i think i was in full uh mullet
attire uh in seattle by 95 so they had
to get the mullet correct
and uh
and just the nemesis and you know kind
of like the pig pen if you will from uh
charlie brown with the big thing of
smoke coming kind of coming up around me
on the mound and all that
how does one tell them to get them all
at right walk me through that it got to
be a certain length i mean like well
i've got they were showing me some uh
you know some top secret uh
you know design some artist renditions
and i said no it's got to be longer
we're talking a mullet come on
i love it just amazing all right we
found out the guy who's got the most
career hits off of you randy johnson we
got it
how many at-bats tj jefferson how many
ipads did he have did you have well it
didn't see the i didn't say that you
just got just got the number of hits
i don't know we
we don't have that number but the number
that we have is 20
20 career hits against you
and give me three names and i'll pick
the person probably okay here we go uh
first name is i will go with piazza
um and then page rodriguez
paul laduka
paul laduka oh yeah and i faced all of
them but like i like i think that mike
piazza probably has the best numbers off
his so i'm going to say he's got 20 hits
off me actually it's paul laduka with
pudge being second that's what we got
here really yeah how about that well so
that's the top three hitters against me
then probably then
what do you what do you got his first
leduc pledges first and for duke is
second okay that said pudge's first luca
duke is second there you go well there
you go there now next time i do uh next
time i do an interview and someone asked
me who are the toughest hitters i've
ever faced well i can say paul laduka
you're much welcome you're you're
welcome randy i try to believe people in
a better spot thank you for that useless
information okay
randy that's what i'm expert at that's
why you know i've been on the air since
96 the year after your first cy young
award man so that's how i've been able
to stick around is by making uh useless
information somewhat useful and then i
guess the the now now that there's no
now that there's no more uh i guess
pitchers being required to hit in major
league baseball do you know how many
career home runs you hit randy johnson
do you know how many careers oh it must
have been at least 15 or 20 i think
i think you should take the under randy
i'm sure you've got your crack engineers
on that on that topic i already have
that information it's written on a card
it's one time you hit one home run you
hit one home run in your career
that's all
it must have been all the batting
practice home runs i hit at various ball
parks those didn't count
i guess not did they not count
apparently not we got one we got one
uh all right well at least i got one
right yeah it was in miller park on
september 19 2003 so we'll call you on
the anniversary of that
how many hormones did i give up oh gosh
you know there's a crazy thing is and
you know when we had nolan on a few
weeks ago he's the all-time leader in
walks too you know i mean farf was the
all-time leader in touchdowns for a
while and interceptions thrown i mean
when you've been at it such a long time
at the top of your game you're bound to
you know lead in everything so that's
like it's like like
everybody will come up how many birds
did you hit how many birds did you kill
over 22 years
apparently same number apparently same
number of home runs you hit randy
yeah but which was a greater feat
well both were moving that you had
that's true i put i put both of those in
very high esteem in my office here i
have the home run ball
in the other corner i have a stuffed dub
[Laughter]
i don't know how you put it back
together randy and i don't mean the home
run ball i mean you know well
i have them both in my office so uh uh
they're
in there
and those are the my two prized
positions
uh prized possessions uh the the
baseball and the and the uh the bird
that i hit
you know the anniversary that just came
up i don't even know where my cy youngs
and my world series trophy
real hard to put that bird back together
randy i really appreciate the time man i
hope we get to do this more often i've
really uh i've really enjoyed it and i
hope you did too thanks again sir well
well
tell your security next time i come down
there and let me in even though i don't
have an appointment yesterday i got
turned turned away uh security escorted
me out of the building we got to make
sure we got to get on that uh we'll make
sure you get on that uh i guess next
time maybe i need to bring like a
baseball card and show them that i
really am ready
or a bird
at r.j
rj51 photos on instagram to check out
this man's work uh behind the lens uh
thanks for the call randy johnson you're
the man
my pleasure you guys do well randy
johnson here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here